okay all right we're back on the
Internet's let's go okay Gary what's the
best way that America can harm putin's
interest yeah how do we get him how do
we get on the offensive hey you have
sanctions and you can tighten the noose
is sanctions have been biting and it's
very important that the Congress will
guarantee that there's no wait for Trump
to leave them go green all his money
comes from oil we got off the oil he
starved right that's not that's not that
many ways because you know he depends
very much on the outside world and it's
very important American shows it's this
political will to oppose him we also
start supporting our NATO allies again
right rather than drawing ourselves
closer to Russians friends yep okay so
Van Steve do you think the media should
change the way it covers president Trump
yes I
you got your boy back in the room now
right and that's a very good thing
[Applause]
I think there's a lot of actually
amazing good stuff it happens in the
country that we don't get a chance to
talk about because you know he just
wakes up in the morning tweets out some
crazy stuff and most of us wake up in
the morning pick up our phone and then
freak out for the next 18 hours and then
go to bed so I think if we could just
give him a little bit less of the oxygen
and give actually I don't know real
people doing real stuff more time would
be better that's not gonna happen
because your network and every network
now has to report to the boardroom they
have to make a profit and profit means
more eyeballs and to get more eyeballs
they do [ __ ] she is on Trump's feed
and she taught me that people respond to
it remember he tried to knock off the
critics and he couldn't do it the
critics are brilliant they revive your
faith than the American people they're
hilarious they're thoughtful they're
funny they're on point yeah although I'm
not gonna get the feeling from her okay
congressman SWA well how should the
incoming Democratic majority and the
House of is he respond to the CIA's
conclusion that the Saudi Crown Prince
was responsible for the death of Jamal
khashoggi you know putting the foreign
policy issue aside give the family his
remains back I mean the president can
insist you know where the remains they
deserve to have closure there but then
beyond that understanding the
president's financial interest in how
it's driving foreign policy we would
never allow an ally to kill a u.s.
resident working for a US publication at
a NATO allies country and so make sure
that he stands up for US values okay
Gary how many moves would it take to
beat Trump in a game of chess
[Laughter]
I feel insulted in my game because we
play by the rules
okay
you're not going on vacation
[Applause]
you